- [Voiceover] The polynomial p
of x has four distinct zeros.
Four distinct zeros.
Which of the following
graphs could represent
y is equal to p of x?
Well, four distinct zeros means
that the graph is going to intersect
the x-axis exactly four times.
So this first one intersects the x-axis
one, two, three times.
So we can rule that one out.
This one intersects the x-axis one, two,
three, four, five times.
So can rule that one out.
This one intersects the x-axis
one, two, three, four times.
It has four distinct zeros.
So this looks like,
this one right over here
looks like our choice.
And this one right over here,
it actually only has two,
two distinct zeros, or at least
that's what it looks like.
So I'd rule that one out as well.
So this is definitely going to be the one
that has four distinct zeros.
Zeros are the x-values
at which the function is equal,
or the polynomial in this case,
and which is a function of x,
is going to be equal to zero.
And you can see that's happening
exactly four times.